is going all out
this is what i wanted wanted to see i
mean i yeah i think you're right i mean
i think the matchup changes dramatically
at different ranges and if anna gets
steve in the vortex it can be can be
tough but then anna has to take so many
risks
it's going to be interesting yeah i mean
one of anna's best neutral tools would
probably be her qcf1
uh which is the the high album that's
the count hit launcher that couldn't be
a terror for steve because i played this
matchup a few times against um uh haroon
actually when he ruins i know and that
could actually be a terror to deal with
um so let's just see how strong is able
to play around that nice just straight
up sonic timer
nice uh step that's the thing and it's
full crunch mix you have to walk it to
the left side what left and you beat it
there is the snake edge can't launch it
just gets a while setting one two up
forward three two okay strong that's how
you feel
walking there to the back
this is classic stroke right now going
to the wall no just shy
doesn't get a full spot
punch nice
stuff like that as well other characters
can launch steve cannot and there it is
vaughn gets on the board as well we have
a tight one already
very patient there oh whilst i need to
yeah just so
unfortunately
oh my gosh big sweep there from van he's
taking a lot of risks right now
all right down back three two stomps on
the toes that one plus two bar needs to
get up down one plus two again
nice patience therefore but the sonic
fang from out of nowhere what is strong
being that we aren't
fight
he's seen that van's pressing a lot of
buttons i guess that must be it
down two one two finishes the string
nice gets the float on the sprinkler
we're going to the walls sonic sang no
messes it up
board one this is looking like strokes
around right now well i need to do
something big he wants to get back into
it interesting
can he carry to the next wall
almost oh threatening in the full crash
mix
just again the sonic bank from out of
nowhere that was clutch
what's he gonna do with it backing
himself into the rage drive spent no
movement there from stroke
oh gets the count here nice size up
there from van to get more damage on the
combo it's not going to be dead though
he gets to the back
four steam of the kit oh this is dead
he's dead he's dead
what a choice oh
i have to vaughn could have won that i
think it was good from there just from
stroke to stay down but ivan did
sidestep three which is a ground hitting
mid um i've that might have killed i
don't know but would have put my
situation to get the kill there that get
out fall really changed around in the
moment struck up he just just sidewalked
put ana's back through and then raised
you everything that was going to be it
then the worst part about that is like
the whole time you're blocking the
punches you just know you're dead
yeah just like um
yeah they both played so well both of
them were just getting their stuff in i
actually thought that um the way van was
using
anna
at close range was quite clever he
wasn't getting pulled into any city
fights he wanted to get into the offense
his way and not not try and get into a
a war of fire with steve it was really
interesting and the way he was using the
wall as well like uh using stance to to
really employ some good mind games and
then peed him off the wall for more
damage and good oaky he was looking good
i think one thing as well i think maybe
while we're seeing stroke use sonic bang
is because um one thing when anna first
came out that most people sort of uh
picked up whatever was her punishment
isn't fantastic
you know when we got fantastic
punishment it improved over time but
something like uh sonic thanks only
minus 12. and it doesn't really get a
great punishment if it hits and i think
strog is making some reads on one's
movement and timing so it's his it's
every time he's doing it hits so uh be
interesting to see
how if we continue up or bond just plays
a bit more patience and i do want to see
vaughn force the mix up a bit more now i
want to see the full quest downward
towards the while since i want to see
more of that he needs to start forcing
his he's like strong is just dominating
too much you need to put the fear of the
mix-up in his heart and try and get your
own start uh your own stuff going
he's doing it well at the wall but maybe
not so much in neutral and that's what
we need to see some changes on
fight
here we go now we're at the howard
estate the party stage
what a read already starts off with the
launch going to the wall
nice patience again but get sidestepped
and we'll get hurt
it's interesting to see as well that uh
vaughn went for a random slope did not
pick stage so you know oh nice running
too they even if you wanted to power
that you couldn't you can't parry
running moves um i know players will
normally let go to the forgotten realm
because she's so strong in that game
stage so many of her moves become normal
hit launchers with a full break
um so it's interesting to see they just
didn't pick a stage
it's that cool circle forward one that
we you talked about earlier barely seen
it at all in this game
i'm like three two one staying down
there
oh going on that one they have to be
very careful that situation but the
cyborg will save stroke there and it's
the watson one two the wild man comer
but nice punish there run up into back
two and nice and extra flicker jab in
there to make sure he could peel off of
the walls stroke is prepared
he really is and he's not he's not being
gonna crush him too much at all where
you know you're looking to crush steve
as much as possible but he's not giving
her the opportunity to do that mm-hmm
going to the war
this is technically a law match as well
oh yeah they're related aren't they
oh but there's the snake edge and we
have to see more of that providers get
going even mr block not going to be
launched
no duck there from stroke down to one
face the string nice power crush there
from vaughn
just staying alive that's what you need
to do there it is the full crash down
for two you need to get those mix-ups
going vaughn needs some momentum right
now
not the best combo goes for the sweep
i'll crush again big whiff not the best
punish from strong but he'll take it
down forward two very nice step from bar
not respecting strog anymore side step
three one more hit the one plus two
there's no great we're going to a final
round second game
decided to bring it more offense and
he's working out for him do you need to
see more of those lows i
[Music]
one will not carry to the wall so nice
just like the spike great patience there
oh
very unfortunate
no
you into duck two into duck two okay i
need to talk about that situation though
that was very unfortunate for vaughn he
did the cjm for those of you who don't
know anna's cat stance where she puts
her leg up has an auto low power where
she gets a launch with the hopkins to do
anything
he did down back three it worked but he
did down by three two and for some
reason the second hit
just